99% of the time I review a new release
after having seen at once it's usually
pretty easy to form an opinion on a film
you see you liked it or you didn't like
it
simple right in the case of it comes at
night which by the way I've already seen
enough jokes about the film's title so
I'm not going to make one here on first
viewing I left the theater so conflicted
I honestly didn't know how I felt so I
went and I saw the film again and tried
to cancel out all anticipation or hopes
that I had and just focus on the
filmmaking having seen it twice now I'm
itching to talk about it in depth so
we're going to get into spoiler
territory here for those who haven't
seen it I encourage you to see the film
if you're interested but I do not think
you should watch the trailers my first
exposure this movie was the brilliant
poster I think it's one of the best of
the year I was so enticed by this poster
and what the dog could possibly be
barking at then there was the trailers
they were so fucking awesome with the
title like it comes at night and
trailers that suggest some terrifying
entity outside this remote forest home I
was salivating to see it then there was
the critics reviews poured out of early
showings reporting that it was genuinely
terrifying devastating and a masterclass
in horror filmmaking I could not have
been more hyped to see it and there's
quite a bit I liked about it this is a
beautifully shot film with gorgeous long
takes and expertly crafted camerawork
the location creates a sense of
isolation that felt so real
it was almost exhausting Joel Edgerton
and he is so damn good here his
performance was emotionally understated
and very realistic the majority of the
acting was really strong from a
technical standpoint it's very
refreshing to see so much care put into
the filmmaking craft on a smaller indie
film like this it's clear that the
director Trey Edward Schultz is very
passionate about his craft and has a
considerable amount of skill as a
director audiences however haven't been
as kind while critics seem to a
Dorit ticket buyers are the polar
opposite it even got a D on CinemaScore
which I don't put any stock in but it
shows you how audiences feel a lot of
this has to do with the incredibly
misleading marketing campaigns as I said
that first poster was so enticing and
the trailers to what is it what's the
dog barking at why doesn't the family go
out at night why is that their number
one rule
well these questions aren't answered we
don't learn what's out there if there's
anything at all and the majority of the
frightening imagery in the trailer is
actually pulled from many extended dream
sequences that the character of Travis
has he'll wake up after having a
nightmare and so far as I can tell these
sequences have little impact on the
story for decades critics have
complained about the overuse of dream
sequences in horror movies I know I have
when I see a horror film and something
really fucked up happens that gets me
excited about where the story could be
going there's nothing more disappointing
than immediately cutting to someone
jolting upwards in bed realizing that
it's all a dream
this happens around four or five times
in the film it's easily the part of the
movie I'm most conflicted about because
Schulz clearly views these sequences as
important during the dreams he alters
the film's aspect ratio from 240 to 275
I noticed during the first dream and in
all the subsequent ones as soon as the
aspect ratio began to change it was
clear that what we were watching wasn't
really happening which for myself
drained all tension from the moment we
are basically being warned ahead of time
by this editing choice that the
following scene isn't happening in
reality and thus will have no impact on
the characters other than to give Travis
a good scare when he awakes in bed
interestingly though towards the end of
the film as the climax begins the aspect
ratio changes once more it goes from 240
all the way to three point zero one and
remains that way until the end credits
the difference here is that Travis isn't
dreaming the best that I can come up
with to interpret this moment is that
the bleak reality Travis is
Berrien Singh has become like a
nightmare the horrifying choices his
father has to make a painful reminder
that reality can be as disturbing as a
nightmare if that's what Schultz is
going for I get it but I found this
editing technique highly distracting
rather than being invested in the
performances and the intensity of the
moment my eyes kept drifting the top and
bottom of the screen noticing the black
bar is fading in and so the image was
heavily crushed by them this finale is
also the first time in the film Schulz
uses handheld cam and I'm assuming that
was to convey the horror of the
situation even more again I get it his
choices are understandable but too often
it feels like editing choices getting in
the way of the moment I couldn't feel
the brilliance of the performances
because essentially it felt like the
film kept getting in the way the witch
faced a similar disappointment from
audiences as did the babadook this often
occurs when critics adore a film and
really go for those pull quotes and then
the marketing lies to the audience
enticing them for a movie that the
filmmaker perhaps wasn't even trying to
make in the first place this is the
biggest reason I wanted to see it twice
now that I knew there was no physical
entity in the film and that the title
was just a metaphor
I hoped that my experience wouldn't be
so conflicting it comes at night is a
wonderfully acted film with experts
cinematography and a startling sense of
tension and isolation but its bare-bones
story lack of resolution and few answers
for its many thought-provoking questions
left me cold I can definitely say this
this is one of those rare movies where I
completely understand every single
reaction to it if you loved it I totally
get that and I wouldn't challenge you at
all if you hated it I could also see all
the reasons why that would make sense
I fall somewhere in between the two
somewhere beyond the aspect ratio tricks
and the unanswered questions there's a
truly stellar film here I look forward
to seeing Schultz's future work because
he's clearly talented but in the end
this film left me rather disappointed I
don't need to be spoon-fed information
and
one of the best things about this movie
is just how little exposition there is
you're introduced to a world where an
unknown virus has spread and we feel
like we're catching up for the first 20
minutes that's really refreshing having
just seen the mummy where Russell Crowe
basically told me a bedtime story for
the first 10 minutes of the movie I
couldn't have been happier with that but
in retrospect there are so many plot
points set up with little to no
resolution what was the dog barking at
in the woods when the dog escaped who or
what injured it how did it end up inside
the house again later who left the door
open why the scene where will seems to
be lying about having a biological
brother how did the boy end up on the
floor at night how did the second family
get sick did they get sick or did Paul
kill them out of fear does anything come
around at night fear paranoia nightmares
Schultz has stated that he deliberately
answers none of these questions because
he wants us to experience the fear and
confusion of the lead characters we only
learned what they learn that's an idea
that has worked in the past so I can
understand why he'd want to try it here
but when you take the time to set up
intriguing plot elements in the script
and then don't live up to addressing
them even remotely well it's clear to me
why so many have expressed frustration
with the film I wanted to love it and
obviously I gave it a fair chance having
seen it twice in one weekend but I've
got to be honest I found the film
unnecessarily highbrow for a story that
is essentially about a family in a house
hiding from a pathogenic outbreak it's
nothing we haven't seen before and the
only thing that separates it from other
films or TV shows of this sort is the
execution beyond that the story did
little to grab me and after two viewings
I haven't been able to latch on to the
director's vision he has said that the
title is a metaphor but it's not clear
to myself or to anyone else I've spoken
to what exactly that is he has also
stated in interviews that everything
that happens off-screen is in his head
he knows what we don't see and he has
purposefully omitted
all answers from the film if that's true
then there really is no way to
accurately interpret it we can only make
theories even if film as confusing as
enemy had a breadcrumb trail woven
throughout for eagle-eyed viewers to
follow it comes at night doesn't seem to
have one and it's clear that that's how
Schulz wants it so guys what did you
think of it comes at night I'm curious
to know because this once again is
another very divisive independent horror
film that critics really loved and
audiences are having a hard time
agreeing with similar to the Witch and
the babadook guys thank you so much as
always for watching if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]
[Applause]